it's done right need to be stripped
crispy a worldwide global brand we
already have cocktail parties around the
world in different different locales and
we have members from around the world
buying our classes and seminars online
so I know that those customers are out
there and I know that the model is
valuable to more people than just
Americans so I feel like it could be
worldwide I also feel like we could
strengthen our reach into the
advertising industry and the public
relations and marketing industries very
tangential industries to the traditional
creative media people so I feel like
there's a lot of growth there in all
these different ways geographically and
also vertically people are always asking
me how you did it and how they can do it
how they can start a business and you
really have to have an idea that you
believe in I hate to kind of regurgitate
clichés but honestly I found those
cliches to be true if you don't believe
in your idea more than anything in the
world if you don't feel every day like
you're having the most fun you've ever
had no matter how hard the chores are no
matter how tedious they are if you don't
feel that it's fun this isn't for you
you can't be an entrepreneur because you
will be taking out the garbage cleaning
up messes you'll be doing the most
mundane ridiculous tasks and that's what
it takes perseverance year after year
month after month to just keep going and
what keeps you going is your excitement
and your passion and those little
trickle in results but the little
results that just trickle in those are
the things that keep you going there's
no sometimes there's no external
gratification there's no money in it
sometimes people are complaining
sometimes people are angry at you
sometimes people are hostile towards you
but you have to keep going because you
have an inner engine that just keeps you
you